I didn't prepare a speech because I just
wanted to feel whatever this is because
Maria is so corrected it's very
difficult for me to open myself to
receive what people have to offer and so
tonight I came prepared to be open and I
would like to thank the Board of
Governors for the opportunity to receive
the love and the Oscar I never imagined
myself receiving an Oscar certainly not
for doing what I believe is a part of my
calling as a part of my being it's a
part of why I am here and what I know
for sure is the only reason I am here is
because Quincy Jones was in a hotel in
Chicago in 1985 and he saw me on am
Chicago and said I think that's Sophia
so I would like to thank Quincy Jones
who is in Dubai right now the journey
from Kosciusko Mississippi where nobody
ever even imagined it possible that you
could be anything other than a maid who
had some good white folks who would give
you clothes and would let you take food
home on the holidays it's unimaginable
that I would be standing before you
voted by the Board of Governors
unimaginable
it's unimaginable
unimaginable
it is unimaginable and so I when I say
thank you
the thank you comes from a place deeper
than even I know Sharon even deeper than
I know because it's not just from me
it's from everybody who made me possible
it's from every shoulder ever stood on
every bridge I ever crossed every story
that's ever told every story that ever
imagined this day to be possible I thank
you for this the ability to tell stories
in such a way that you connect to the
heart space of people and you connect to
the place where people really live and
not just live but where their souls
abide that is what great films do and to
this day the color purple experience is
one of the greatest experiences of my
life
and yes I'd like to do more films but to
receive the Jean Hersholt Humanitarian
Award means more to me than any film any
acclaim even an Oscar because what it
says is that you all get it the Board of
Governors you get it you have voted for
what I believe is the essence of why
we're all here we're all here to help
each other we're all here to use our
lives in service to one another thank
you so much
you